[Música]
el que fuese uno de los botánicos
más importante de todos nuestros tiempos
el célebre valenciano antonio josé
cabanillas
describió más de 2.000 especies
vegetales muchas de ellas nuevas es
decir las descubrió
en su libro observaciones sobre el reino
de valència que escribió en 1797 en el
que recorrió toda nuestra geografía
valenciana nos mostró todas las bondades
de nuestros suelos rurales
suelo fértil
abundantes aguas cielo hermoso sano y
despejado
en el mismo se formulaba una pregunta
donde hay en españa fuera del reino de
valencia donde hay en europa
semejante porción de tierra tan útil
sana fresca alegre y divertida
gracias verdad
al mismo tiempo respondió la afirmación
es que se gloría los valencianos
de poseer una de las porciones más ricas
de europa y muestran
sus frutos y sus gentes
222 años después
tenemos tres factores fundamentales que
son los factores que hacen que podamos
tener un cultivo de excelencia y lo
seguimos manteniendo cómo es la calidad
de nuestras tierras de nuestras aguas y
de nuestro sol
desgraciadamente la cosa ha cambiado y
de qué manera
actualmente abandonamos 88 hectáreas de
suelo de cultivo en la comunidad
valenciana' diariamente y ya sumamos
170.000 hectáreas de suelo productivo de
suelo cultivable y que tenemos en estado
de abandono
lo que lo podríamos traducir en que
estamos perdiendo la posibilidad de
generar alimentos para 600 53 mil
personas diariamente
a que conlleva eso pues bueno aparición
de plagas
deshidratación de acuíferos
contaminación
incendios
y a más a más estamos importando
alimentos de otros continentes para
satisfacer y para generar para dar
nuestras necesidades de forma diaria e
innecesaria
como decía josep pla la cocina es el
paisaje puesto en la cazuela
y si nos paramos a pensar con este 25
por ciento del suelo cultivable que
tenemos en estado de abandono
seguramente pocos de nosotros se
llevaría nuestro paisaje a un plato
desde el año 1835 que somos la primera
potencia mundial en la producción de
cítricos un referente a nivel planetario
y hoy nuestros cítricos nuestras
cosechas ya no valen
miles y miles de hectáreas se están
abandonando este año
y al mismo tiempo tenemos un problema
extremadamente grave con la diversidad
vegetal
según la fao desde el año 1900 hasta el
se ha perdido el 75% de la diversidad
agrícola vegetal una pérdida vegetal que
conlleva a la pérdida de una cultura
y una identidad
nuestra identidad
todo ello supone una terrible amenaza no
solo para nuestra biodiversidad sino
también para nuestras especies de
animales
de tierra y de mar
tenemos la obligación no sólo de detener
todos estos problemas sino que al mismo
tiempo tratar de repararlo de la mejor
forma posible
y hay mucho más trasfondo en todo ello
no sólo podemos hablar de un paisaje
degradado sino que podemos hablar de lo
más importante que tenemos los cada ser
humano cada individuo y es nuestra salud
hemos abandonado
la alimentación que realmente deberíamos
adoptar
y a más a más tenemos problemas graves
de diabetes en niños
diabetes de tipo 2 que actualmente
antiguamente se daba única y
exclusivamente en adultos y actualmente
se dan niños somos uno de los países con
mayor obesidad infantil
tenemos problemas extremadamente graves
a nivel de cardiovascular y todo eso
viene dado a una incorrecta alimentación
hemos perdido el valor del original el
valor de abrir la puerta del patio de
recolectar nuestras propias vegetales
nuestras propias verduras y cocinar las
que actualmente es a simple acción
podría ser tener un agricultor de
confianza un agricultor de proximidad al
que le encomendamos nuestra alimentación
y nuestra salud
según la oms cada individuo deberíamos
ingerir diariamente 400 gramos de fruta
verdura y hortaliza
diariamente y no alcanzamos un 25%
la judía el garbanzo la lenteja son
legumbres
y vegetales auténticos de nuestra propia
dieta mediterránea y que tan solo
estamos consumiendo 12 gramos diarios y
prácticamente la totalidad le importamos
de terceros países porque hemos
abandonado sus cultivos y por cierto el
pasado 10 de febrero la onu declaró el
día mundial de las legumbres
por una triple apuesta para luchar
contra el hambre
contra la salud y el medio ambiente
llama su organismo dependiente encargado
de la alimentación y de la agricultura
la fao considera imprescindible y
fundamental que incrementemos el consumo
de legumbres principalmente por su
fuente de nutrientes y porque significa
un desarrollo para cualquier tipo de
zona rural para nuestras abandonadas
zonas rurales
que estamos comiendo si no comemos
vegetales
pues carne
para producir 500 gramos de una chuleta
de buey
necesitamos 7000 litros de agua
las emisiones
a la atmósfera el 30 por ciento de las
emisiones que emitimos hoy en día
provienen de la industria
agroalimentaria
todos conocemos el caso del metano
supongo supongo que emiten las vacas
en el año 2017
el mar mediterráneo autos sus recursos
en el mes de septiembre
en el 2018
en agosto
se estima que en el año 2030
habrán desaparecido los peces que hoy en
día estamos consumiendo
nuestros hijos ya no van a hablar de la
sardina del rape del mero de la merluza
pensemos un minuto en lo que ahora está
tan de moda y denominamos volver al
pasado en el mundo de la cocina
y en ese agricultor que os decía ese
agricultor de proximidad
necesitamos trabajar entre todos para
erradicar estos problemas porque como
bien he dicho con ello lleva o te
llevamos nuestra salud
y como decía josep pla perdón como decía
el botánico cavanilles
necesitamos un entorno sano feliz alegre
y divertido como es el entorno
valenciano de nuestra agricultura urbana
y periurbana
y ahora me gustaría
ya para concluir pensar en nuestros
abuelos la gente que se vivió que
trabajó de sol a sol por nosotros y que
pensemos en nuestros nietos en que
tratemos de labrar les un futuro con
salud
y que ellos nos recuerden como yo
recuerdo mi yayo
y que recordemos todos a nuestros
antepasados o sea que nuestros nietos
nos recuerden como nosotros recordamos a
nuestros antepasados
y creemos entre todos entre todos un
entorno verde
un entorno cuidado
y un espacio único en europa gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
pero